rich are you there I am Adam how are you
sir good to speak to you always um you
know it's funny I just uh I'm soothed
just to hear the name Rich Eisen I
really do for fight it's it's it's like
it's like a bomb it's like a bomb is
what you're saying yeah yeah bomb with
the with an L ESF yeah yeah it's it's
like with an L both with elves yes yeah
like instead of Nam Yoho rengay Kyo I'd
just be rich eyes mm-hmm feel better
already good the rich out I should show
by the way even you'd watch hard knocks
last night let me tell you man that
that's a hell of a show those NFL Films
people are just the bomb they're the
best I mean it's unbelievable what they
get and how comfortable people are
around them and are you excited for the
return of your Rams to Los Angeles uh
yeah yeah I am it's so weird I mean I'm
really excited honestly because my son
is into it you know for me they left
what 21 years ago or something like that
the hell's it been but right before they
left during my sort of formative
football years and now they're back and
if the game has passed me by a little
bit but my son is going to be in too and
I'll relive it through the eyes of babes
but the yes that the show looks amazing
but kind of my thing with hard knocks is
it looks too good like I think they're
getting a little too caught up in the
cinematography I want to see guys
crashing into each other not beautiful
miss us bring you know you don't see
sprinkler heads turn it on so what do I
think that's the shot that did it
because I got they got enamored with two
shots the sprinkler head and then the
sprinkler head and the dragonfly and
slow motion taken off after the
sprinkler fired up and I'm like the
first 20 minutes of it was just nothing
but sweeping vistas of the Santa Monica
Bay
I want to seem to do the jockstrap I
want to see the guy and where's the Turk
I don't want it I don't want to steal
the Turk the Turk aim for a guy who
brought a woman to the to the dorm yeah
but that was Fisher that was very sure I
know but it was I want to turn what are
just what do you want to see an actual
guy named Turk go well no well hurt what
I'm saying is is I want the executioner
I went the hangman I don't want the
mayor of the city to pull the lever you
know what I'm saying he's the mayor get
the turkey if I were Fisher before I
canned my quarterback I would have said
has it gone how the kids how's Shelly
good has a vacation been traveling hold
on somebody wants to talk to you and
then handing the phone to the Turk and
he'd be like York and and then he'd
handed back and go how's the vacation
has the kids gone anything yeah I think
he kept I thought he did that with Foles
to when he got fulls on the phone like
hell was going on okay yeah hey we're
releasing you later today ok that's
great hope all's well bye I mean but
that is the sort of stuff that that's
the way things go you know behind the
scenes and stuff like Greg Williams the
defensive coordinator caught on
microphone talk about how their
quarterbacks never been under center
before and doesn't call plays in a
huddle you know and and is kind of
lamenting that as his defense is ready
to roll in the NFL and I think he's
concerned that the other side of the
ball might not be able to hold its own I
mean that's the sort of stuff that I
think fans dig about the hard knocks I
was thinking I wonder I was just
harkening back to Fisher and how
casually he cuts people his wife's got
to worry every time he calls right like
hey sweetie hi just checking up you are
you coming back from Color Me Mine good
i want you to swing by the store to pick
up to make oh we're getting divorce
anyway hows of it that's dimi do it like
yeah every time the phone rings she's
got to just stare at it everybody in
that camp every time Fisher calls has to
just stare at it breaking her cold sweat
right yes exactly and and it would be it
might be that might be the first time
caller
mine would ever be part of an NFL
related show the pottery painting look
how I love it that is you know what man
that is that would be a new Hard Knocks
the culinary minds are not the color me
mine heart now with the Turk be dressed
in a certain way though what I like in
you know I'm I I like the sort of Roman
you know sort of the gladiator kind of
tuning kind of studded you know leather
you know sleeveless obviously yeah that
that's obviously I'm an old school guy
so I like that look but just just so
we're clear the Turk does the firing and
I need him to do least escort the guy
into the gallows I don't want the code
picking up the blower doing it himself
but but they would they would they would
they would provide a box for their
belongings though correct I mean at
least before before that happens I'd end
it leaves yeah I gather your things
bring your PlayBook I so rich what do
you think like which way is the wind
blowing out here in terms of the Rams
their acceptance the fans the enthusiasm
level like we're where we at if you were
to give it a one to ten number oh I
would put its I would put it in the
eight to nine range right now for sure I
mean that the the the attendance at
training camp down in Irvine is is is
really good and then the people talking
that I know that are going to these both
preseason games they are fired up for
that and then week two when Pete Carroll
of all people comes back to the Coliseum
to bring Seattle in against the rams who
the last several years in st. Louis
played Seattle perhaps better than
anybody in the division year in year out
um that is a certain level of excitement
that I am sensing for sure and you know
the question is is is how good is the
team going to do to keep that enthusiasm
going deep into week eight nine ten
what's going to happen then I think a
lot of eyes are peeled thinking that
Southern Californians will bolt or not
be into a team that might be three and
five or four and four and I know Fisher
said last night in what I guess the most
talked-about soliloquy from Hard Knocks
it is one Easy's not going seven and
nine or eight Nate but you know that
wouldn't be actually very bad for a team
that that hasn't you know well to be
fair to going through a lot though I
mean to be fair to Fisher he ran through
every numerical possible combination of
a 16 game series we're not going 115
we're not going a half in 15 and a half
we're not going to go heavy he literally
went through every day permeate
fermentation of that girl from he did he
did run the gamut from seven and nine
all the way to ten and six right it do
but I did notice and stopping abruptly
ten and six so are you know it you have
to also figure a lot of these people are
still moving in a homer they're still
trying to figure out what their
surroundings are this is a this is a
major logistical um situation for the
Rams as well as trying to play football
just trying to get used to every new
surrounding and then get ready for a
season with a guy who as you saw last
night is quite green at quarterback and
so when you hear that case keenum is a
real shot to start week one on Monday
night the last game of week one in San
Francisco and maybe even the home opener
against Seattle you have to believe it
so it'll never took snaps under center
because they ran out a shotgun his
entire you find for most college kids
yeah and that was one of the knocks on
both Winston and Mariota two years ago
as are they really worth it because
Mariota and Oregon has never turned his
rarely if ever turned his back to the
defense in a in a play-action situation
a lot of these guys uh it's a it's a
large it's a very large uh you know hill
to climb to get ready for the season but
then mario de came out through four
touchdowns and didn't even have to
finish his first game as a pro and all
of a sudden that went out the window so
you don't know I mean golf might be able
to hit the ground running but I don't
know if he's going to get the chance at
this point well let me make this analogy
Rich Eisen host advertise and showing
directv it is interesting because you
talk about quarterback
actually talk about quarterbacks getting
sacked and then you talk about back sack
and what I'm talking about is getting
used to getting other underneath another
man's body and touching your hands
tightly up in like that yes that's night
did you like the knuckle discussion I
did enjoy the drop in the digit on the
center with all the tank tops but it is
trade sort of like boy like if you don't
grow up with it it's weird when you're
22 you know that means it's got to be
part of your diet you know from peewee
football on you can't just take it i
would agree and go hey this is called
Vegemite you might enjoy it like no it's
got to be part of you have to eat it as
an infant in order or you're going to
gag I just feel like that's not
something he was into and it's hard to
make that transition but we shall see
how it goes if we shall see yeah raekwon
one last question at Tebow what do we
think about his chances of making it I
love it I think for sure in and and a
major league baseball team is going to
take a shot on him I think they're for
sure gonna stick him in there a minor
league system and see how it works for
the for the very least that uh you know
minor league affiliates really uh you
know it'll be perfect for him it would
be pretty wants to ride the bus he's
gonna want to do that but people like
Deion Sanders have done it and Michael
Jordan's done it and I think t-bo's
going to really understand that that's
what it's all about and I think he will
bring that work ethic and give it a
whirl I can't wait to see it i really i
think it's going to happen well it is
it's kind of interesting i was thinking
about this and speaking about on my
program as well which is baseball
there's a lot of work ethic and there's
that in every sport but I mean let's
face it in basketball and and in
football as well if you don't have those
sort of god-given whatever it's going to
be tough to overcome it with hard work I
mean we're not living in the Rocky
Bleier era but in baseball if you have
the tools but you also work twice as
hard as everyone else spend all the time
in the cage and so on and so forth all
the BP in his work ethic
his sobriety and not getting laid and
all the other distractions alive I can I
am a pretty good chance right I look I
mean it's he hasn't played in 10 years
it's a you know i think it's a it's an
incredibly difficult learning curve he
may not make the majors but in the
minors riding the bus and giving it a
try and then maybe somebody calls him up
in September if not this year next year
obviously this year's a very long long
long shot why not I mean why wouldn't a
major league baseball team give it a
shot Russell Wilson's been drafted by
two different teams Manziel got drafted
by the Padres I mean there's a many many
football players that have been drafted
by baseball teams just on a lark so why
not Tim Tebow Russell's going to be on
your program today no Bob Bob Griese
will be on the show and Ron Rivera the
coach of the Panthers it still and we
wrap it up and play today yeah oh yeah
yeah now you can give me a couple steps
the Rich Eisen show on directv's
audience what can i say i love myself
some rich eisen thanks so much for phone
and enrich I appreciate it always aced
man you take care the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience